the liberal media full of scorn and
hatred for this American the world
remembering Henry Kissinger who died at
his home in Connecticut yesterday at the
age of a 100 Kissinger dominated foreign
policy for generations and his legendary
life includes fleeing Nazi Germany as a
teen to escape the Holocaust serving in
the US Army and earning a bronze star
President Nixon appointing him as
National Security adviser in 1969 and
ultimately serving as Secretary of State
for both Nixon and President Ford but
Rolling Stone and Huffington Post
smearing him as America's most notorious
war criminal Dana Pino
explain why they're calling him a war
criminal well they okay so this is a guy
he lived a hundred years he's an
immigrant to the United States becomes
an Intel officer during the war and then
he works his way up to be the national
adviser to the Pres to two presidents
and also friend to many others and an
informal adviser to all the other living
presidents and he had a very
consequential life he made some
decisions or advised on some decisions
that for example Cambodia that if you
look at the Rolling Stone they will say
here are all the reasons why he's a war
criminal he had critics throughout his
life what I love about him is that he
didn't let that Define him he didn't let
that hold him back from making decisions
and having a big life he was still up
until about six months ago writing books
about consequential leaders of the world
that's an excellent book by the way I
think you would actually really like
that one as well he wrote about
artificial intelligence he was writing
about the things that we need to worry
about for the next 40 years because he
loved this world he wanted to do the
best for the most people that he
possibly could he said something very
interesting and I would say this to the
critics many of the critics by the way
he outlived them so there would probably
be more today uh one of the one of the
writers that is a correspondent who
contributed to the New York Times
obituary
died 13 years ago okay so he had a big
life but he said this to know something
with total
certainty means knowing absolutely
everything about the situation or
absolutely nothing meaning that you have
the information that you have you do
your very best you make decisions and
you move forward there are people who
then would say he's a hero if you look
at the outcome of the Cold War that was
a good outcome sure was Kil me I uh my
interaction with him I had a lot of them
in fact I had one three weeks ago at the
Al Smith dinner went and talk to him he
was right on the money he was working on
a speech up until the last minute before
he was up there I mean he cares about
everything number thing number two is
he's always smiling and number three is
soccer I I knew him and and and uh got
to know him on soccer saw the impact he
may brought in bringing the World Cup
here he simply used all his power and
Prestige to bring it here there would be
no MLS without the 94 World Cup so that
means there'd be no top league and Messi
would not have been in Miami there would
be no stadiums and we would not know how
uh devastatingly handsome Beckham is
only from the newspapers CU he would
never have come here had no League to
play in sports diplomacy was a part of
his yeah that seems like a black mark if
you ask me on Legacy I know you're not a
big soccer guy Katie I would say that
making resolved principal consequential
decisions takes a lot of courage and he
had to make a lot of big decisions and
there's a reason why people from across
the political aisle sought out his
advice from across the world wanted to
know what he thought about a number of
situations not just based on his
experience but because of decisions that
he had made throughout his appointments
and the work that he had done and I'm
really grateful that he had written up
until six months ago because he
documented so much world and American
history firsthand and if people are
willing to be open-minded they could go
read from that perspective and learn a
lot about the history of the country uh
over the past 50 60 years and about his
life and other people like him who
respected him and wanted to know why he
made the decisions he did Harold Ford Jr
he was uh everybody said it his impact
in Legacy um will resonate continues to
resonate in our relations in the Middle
East and Russia and China um he was
important because he willed himself to
be important he was he was a student of
History he loved history it it informed
him it transformed the way he thought
about things and I think the thing that
whether you like him or not what he
believe most then was that America's
power and credibility was the most were
the two most important things in us
being able to impact and and shape world
events not for just that moment but
going forward did he get it right all
the time of course not no one is perfect
but I got to tell you thank God for him
may God Rest his soul may he rest in
peace and I know one thing uh there was
no better and more tireless advocate for
peace in his hundred years on on this
Earth in my lifetime uh than Henry
Kissinger so best of his family all
right and I wish we could all around
this table live 100 years that would be
great God bless all of
us the fastest is up next hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else